do you miss working for leo burnett
[ __ ] no dude why not sucked well it was
awesome what was going on
but i don't know that was your dream job
yeah when we worked when we worked
together in clearwater
yeah that was like mad men leo burnett
working in a big building in downtown
in downtown chicago or big tobacco
big tobacco that was like your dream
working on marlborough
you thought that that was the pinnacle
of your of existence
that was my existence that was all i
worked for and yeah just like any
grass is always greener but as soon as
you get there you find out it's the same
shitty grass that you were looking at
just from a different perspective
you get there it's great it's cool this
is fun's as awesome as everything i ever
wanted it to be and then like
it becomes normal and then you start to
see it for what it is and
70 hours a week that ain't cool
it's a lot cool if you like it though
you burn out super quick like 70 hours a
week for like
a year and a half they'll catch up to
anybody man
yeah it ain't worth i mean it's like
it's cool like i'm really grateful
that i like stepped out and did that and
personally i don't know who what leo
burnett is like the biggest
most like established oldest most elite
advertising agency in the country yeah
if you've ever seen a commercial they
probably made it yeah
they did they had mcdonald's for a super
long time so like every mcdonald's
commercial up until like five years ago
they made
they've done all the marlboro
advertising since the 50s and it's still
and yeah it's like craft kellogg uh
miller
so that's like coors uh what a miller
high life like all those [ __ ] beers
nintendo was the floor below us that was
sick but yeah
i mean i'm sure you've experienced it
too like you get to a certain point with
something where you're like striving for
it and like
if i just get that that's what i need
and then you get there it's like okay
cool now what
then you're just like there and you're
just like looking and it's like there's
still always something more
it's miserable it wasn't me would you
say it was miserable yeah for sure like
towards the end i was super it was super
miserable
really yeah and i did everything i
wanted to what was your favorite
what what made you want to be in
advertising like what was like
obviously you're good at design and [ __ ]
and you're creative and you love music
and but why why an ad agency
advertising is everything so like if you
think about like a commercial
it's not just like what it looks like
it's like what it looks like what does
it sound like what is the writing
and it's just like a complete total
creative immersion
of a vision for something and you're
selling something which makes it even
more challenging
which is what i like most about it's not
just like creativity for the sake of
like
being creative i was never really good
at being creative like that you know
i feel like i need a problem to solve
and advertising is all about
solving problems creatively like oh we
need to inform these people about
this thing in this way so you have to
take that messaging and then
turn it into a commercial
so you're saying that you like the
process
of trying to sell just as much as you
like the process of like creating the
art
yeah the messaging it's like propaganda
for a product
where you almost have to brainwash
people into believing that it's good
it's like
you know go to mcdonald's oh my
hamburger doesn't look like the picture
yeah no [ __ ] [ __ ] it's an ad you
[ __ ] dumbass
what did you expect i think there's
[ __ ] food stylist in the back of
mcdonald's
in the drive-thru but after
seeing what i've seen and like the
places i've like gone and worked and
[ __ ] it's like
you can do anything from anywhere with
the right attitude like you don't need
to be
somewhere physically to do something
cool you just got to be in a good place
mentally and like have the right
attitude and like want to do the work
and you can do [ __ ] from [ __ ]
anywhere nobody's going to an office
anymore
it doesn't matter you don't need to be
in a [ __ ] city anymore that's why i
feel bad for people like mark
why is that because like i mean people
like me
and you and danielle we're just like we
don't we like yeah we don't have to go
to a [ __ ] office anymore we can work
from home we like working from home
like subcontractors people who do
creative work people who do
whatever employees of creative companies
they get to like they love working from
home and they hate the fact they have to
go to an office but i also sympathize
with people like mark because they
they like they cr mark created that
big-ass office downtown
great beautiful place and he was like it
gave him life
to see employees go in their purpose and
it gave
that was literally like his oxygen yeah
and now it's like left
it's just like a rush people don't want
to go there bro people do not want to go
in there
no and i feel bad for people like him
because i can relate to him as much as i
can relate to people like you know
myself you and danielle you know what i
mean
so it's it's weird it's a weird it's a
weird thing i don't know
i don't know i feel bad because i think
there's something to
like going into an office i do miss the
like
even though a connection yeah with
people and like as much as like
i used to [ __ ] hate to like hey how's
your morning going
oh hey what's up it's like [ __ ]
we just talked like
six hours ago it's like what's so fun
give me a minute when danielle first met
you
she called me or she texted me right
after the time she first met you
she goes why the [ __ ]
are you and luke like why do you guys
act like the same person
you guys have like the same demeanor and
the same like shitty sarcastic tone
we spent a lot of time together we spent
way too much time together it was
so [ __ ] funny bro that rules that was
great that was a funny ass
thing to like read just to hear her like
make that connection
because like i felt like when i would go
to i would go into the office
like prior to
like us linking back up i would go into
the hoth maybe
a day a week two days a week whenever
they had free lunch whenever they had
free lunch
fridays free lunch friday i would go in
and even though i went there one day a
week i felt like that like how you
described like i'd walk in there i'd be
like
of course i was strolling at 11 o'clock
yeah everyone else has been there since
eight
and i'd be walking in and seeing
everybody like in their little cubicles
doing their own thing
like in their own little worlds with
their dogs and their cats and their
whatever the [ __ ] they have their flair
and i'm just like i don't [ __ ] want
to even make eye contact with anybody
you know i mean i don't want to [ __ ]
be here it's just not blinders
but at the same time there's like a huge
benefit
it's like doing this like walking into
that studio is the same thing for me
walking into that office and passing all
those employees and saying hi to people
is the same thing for me
as sitting down here and having like a
four hour conversation with somebody i
don't know
yeah it's like the same uncomfortable
thing
feeling where like i don't like it i'm
uncomfortable with it i don't want to do
it
but i get something from it it shakes
you up a little bit and i think the
thing that you miss about it now it's
like
it's really great to like have the
option
to hate something when it's just pushed
in front of you
it's like yes here's this thing i don't
like this thing but it's here no matter
what yeah
i don't like this thing but now it's
like taken away i was like actually i
kind of missed that like yeah
why did i hate that in the first place
right why did that bother me so much
yeah yeah you want things more when you
can't have or when they're
an option or when you can't have them
yeah
but i don't know discipline is like the
biggest thing
i think i think discipline is is one of
the biggest things that i've learned
from this
or like learning from talking to people
or learning from i mean discipline is
one of like the most important things i
think into like coming up with creative
[ __ ]
yeah is is having is being disciplined
about like even a routine
or processes of doing [ __ ]
or sitting down and trying to get better
at something like
it doesn't matter how good how creative
you are creative doesn't mean anything
it literally is like it means nothing
unless you
have discipline with it at the same time
creative is just like
how many times can you show up and tell
have the same attitude it's
talent with no direction
yeah i mean to a point but like
anybody can be creative it's a muscle
like you said earlier it's like you just
got to show up and like do the work and
prepare your
self and when i say self i mean like
your head like your mind your body and
like everything like you can't think of
[ __ ] unless you're like
snapping in like peak performance and
you gotta treat yourself like an athlete
to be able to think clearly and to be
able to come up with like really cool
[ __ ] that people want to hear it's like
you know like you work out a lot you do
like the supplements and like you care
about that kind of [ __ ] and like you
care about like
like brain optimization health
optimization
and it's no different than the way like
people in the ufc treat themselves or
the people like
at any like elite level treat themselves
like
this is a job yeah like i don't [ __ ]
drink during the week
like i treat my like i eat super clean
i stay super hydrated all the time and
like i make sure that i get enough sleep
because
you know that's how you perform and then
that's how you develop that your brain
and like if you show up like whatever
you want to work on whether it's like
being creative whether it's talking to
people
whether it's [ __ ] playing fortnite
like you got to be in the right state of
mind to be able to
to create and produce and like rise
above everybody else
yeah what's up world you just watched a
clip from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly
pure uncut content straight from the
jungles of columbia if you want to watch
the full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos peace